the freedom to travel across borders in
europe
is one of the most tangible benefits for
people in the european union
millions of people in the union rely on
this
including workers and students
because of the coronavirus pandemic many
national governments have introduced
travel restrictions
in the past month it is indeed very
important
to try to limit the spread of the virus
but citizens are often left confused
about where they can travel
which rules they have to respect on the
way
what must they do on arrival to stay
safe
and as many citizens have experienced
these
rules change very often so we need to
ensure more clarity and predictability
and this is why today the commission is
proposing a common approach
on any measures restricting free
movement to our member states
first we are proposing a common color
code
citizens need to be able to clearly
identify
the risk areas across europe our agency
ecdc
will issue every week an updated map
based on the information that national
governments provide
on this map every region and country
would be
green orange or red
depending on the epidemiological
situation
second we also propose a common approach
to the restrictions
that are introduced for travelers that
come from red zones
we believe that no eu citizen should be
denied entry
to another eu country instead
we recommend governments to use testing
or quarantine testing should be the
preferred option
to make it easier for people to travel
and here
too the rules for the different zones
should be unmistakable
these measures will provide more
stability more predictability
and clarity for europeans